savane fils tué un enfant de dieu tu as
une mission le seigneur a mis sans toi
les personnes ne pourra te le bras suis
un garçon à par nathaniel on peut dire
que l'esclave savent se tenir
disons qu'ils craignent dieu l'un d'eux
est un prêcheur écouter le bien et
peut-être vous irait au paradis
soumettez vous à vos maîtres en tout
respect
tu te prends pour qui le mec je te pose
une question tu ne pressera plus pendant
un moment tu as retenu la leçon
oui je fais bien retenu va se battre je
triche pour que vous chantiez un champ
nouveau fait les louanges élevé de dieu
soit dans leur bouche et qui tiennent
dpa doute tranchant pour exécuter la
vengeance contre les nations des
moniales chantant les seychelles